♪ ♪
>> YOU SAY THAT YOU WILL DO
WHATEVER YOU CAN TO REDUCE THE
IMPACT OF HIGH GAS PRICES ON
AMERICAN.
WE ARE ASKING OTHER COUNTRIES TO
THINK ABOUT MAY BE PUMPING MORE
OIL.
WHY NOT TO WAIT HERE?
>> TO BE VERY CLEAR, FEDERAL
POLICIES ARE NOT LIMITING THE
SUPPLIES OF OIL AND GAS.
LET ME FINISH, LET ME FINISH.
PETER...
LET ME GIVE YOU THE FACTS HERE.
I KNOW THAT CAN BE INCONVENIENT,
BUT I THINK THEY ARE IMPORTANT
IN THIS MOMENT.
THERE ARE 9,000 APPROVED
DRILLING PERMITS NOT BEING USED.
THE SUGGESTION THAT WE ARE NOT
ALLOWING COMPANIES TO DRILL IS
INACCURATE.
>> Jesse: JEN PSAKI BLOWING UP
ON THEIR VERY OWN PETER DOOCY,
GETTING A LITTLE DEFENSIVE OVER
EXPLODING GAS PRICES APPEAR AT
THE COST OF A GALLON IS NOW OVER
$4 NATIONALLY.
THE PRESIDENT'S PLAN TO DEAL
WITH IT IS TO KISS UP TO
DICTATORS INSTEAD OF PRODUCING
MORE OIL AT HOME.
BIDEN ADVISORS ARE TOYING WITH A
POSSIBLE TRIP TO SAUDI ARABIA TO
BEG, BEG FOR MORE ENERGY
PRODUCTION.
U.S. OFFICIALS ARE HOLDING WHERE
FACE-TO-FACE MEETINGS WITH
VENEZUELA.
AND A NUCLEAR DEAL WITH IRAN TO
BE WRAPPED UP AT ANY MOMENT.
THE WHITE HOUSE ALSO SAYING NO
DECISION BEING MADE ON BANNING
FOREIGN AND RUSSIAN OIL AND
NIKKI HALEY UNLOADING ON THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION PEER AT HER
>> WE NEED TO START STANDING UP
WHY ARE WE EVEN A HUMMING AROUND
THE FACT THAT WE ARE STILL
TAKING RUSSIAN OIL?
WHY ARE WE DOING THAT?
WHY WOULD WE TAKE MONEY FROM
EVIL DICTATORS?
YOU NEVER SLEEP WITH THE DEVIL
BECAUSE THE DEVIL OWNS YOU.
THE EUROPEANS ARE FINDING THAT
OUT RIGHT NOW.
WE NEED TO BE SMARTER THAN THAT.
>> Jesse: WE NEED TO REALLY BE
SMARTER, AND YOU WERE MENTIONING
IRAN DEAL THAT IS NOW ON THE
ROPES BECAUSE RUSSIA IS NOW
SAYING, HEY, HEY, HEY, YOU NEED
US ON THIS PIER THEY WANT OIL
FROM THE IRANIANS.
WHERE DOES THAT WHEN I GO?
>> WITH RUSSIA'S HELP WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO GET THE IRAN DEAL WE
NEVER WANTED.
AND GARY SAID IT PERFECTLY, WHO
KNEW VLADIMIR PUTIN WAS EXILED
BECAUSE OF IT?
WHAT DO YOU THINK VLADIMIR PUTIN
THINKS?
THIS IS THE COUNTRY THAT IS
HELPING US OUT DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY TARGETING NUCLEAR
POWER PLANTS IN THE UKRAINE WELL
THREATENING NUCLEAR WAR ON US IF
WE DO XYZ.
NOW, TO GO IN THERE AND CONVINCE
IRAN THAT WE ARE RESPONSIBLE AS
THEY ARE WITH NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
SO TO CUT A DEAL THAT NOBODY,
DAN I KNOW YOU KNOW THIS AND
VOTED AGAINST 2015 PEEL AND
SENATOR SCHUMER VOTED AGAINST
THE DEAL BUT THAT IS A
22015 DEAL NUCLEAR BASIS TO DO
INSPECTIONS AND FUND TERROR.
REAL QUICK TO CLOSE US OUT.
WE ARE ABOUT TO DO A WERE STILL
AT THE WORST THING IS NOBODY
KNOWS ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
WE ARE ABOUT TO DO SOMETHING
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS THAT WILL
AFFECT WORLD PEACE, ESPECIALLY
THE MIDDLE EAST MIDDLE EAST.
BECAUSE WE PUT ALL THOSE
SANCTIONS ON IRAN, WE GOT THE
ABRAHAM ACCORDS.
I WILL TAKE ISRAEL AND
SAUDI ARABIA SIDE OVER THE EVIL
REGIME.
>> Jesse: AND THEY DON'T WANT
THIS IRAN DEAL BUT BIDEN, TELL
US HOW THIS WILL LOOK
DANA PERINO?
AIR FORCE TOUCHES DOWN IN
RIYADH, DOWN ON THE TARMAC AND
GREETS THE KING AND THE KING --
ARE AMERICANS GOING TO GO FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT RIGHT NOW?
>> Dana: WITH AVIATORS ON?
I WILL FOREVER MAKE SURE THAT IT
IS CLEAR THAT WE WERE SEEING
RECORD GAS PRICES BEFORE RUSSIA
INVADED UKRAINE, OKAY?
NUMBER ONE WHEN YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT ENERGY POLICY IN THE
UNITED STATES, START THERE.
UNFORTUNATELY IT LOOKS LIKE IT
WILL GET WORSE.
YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
BASICALLY, WE ARE WILLING TO
LOOK PAST ALL THE HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS IN SAUDI OR
VENEZUELA.
WE ARE OKAY WITH THE FACT THAT
IRAN WANTS TO DESTROY ISRAEL,
BUT WE WILL GO GET THEM TO STEAL
AND MAYBE TAKE OIL.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE MIGHT
NEED TO BE A WAY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO GET MORE OIL IF RUSH IS
GOING TO BE CUT OUT.
I GET THAT.
BUT I ALSO THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO SAY,
WE HAVE TO TRANSITION TO GREEN
ENERGY.
THEY ARE JUST NOT SOBER MINDED
ENOUGH TO SAY, WE NEED TO DO
THESE THINGS ALL AT ONCE.
IF THEY DON'T ANNOUNCED A SHIFT,
NO ONE WILL EVER SAY THEY DID
IT.
THEN GOING TO SAUDI AND IRAN IS
NOT THE SHIFT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
>> Jesse: GOOD LUCK APPEARANCE
BEFORE WE AS A NATION WANT TO
GET TO CLEANER, GREENER ENERGY
EFFICIENT BUT IT WILL TAKE SOME
TIME UNTIL THE SQUAD TO SIT
DOWN.
THEN YOU WALK THEM THROUGH AND
YOU SAY I PUT A TON OF MONEY AND
INNOVATION BUT IN THE MEANTIME
WE WILL GO TO VISIT TEXAS.
WE ARE GOING TO PENNSYLVANIA.
WE WILL GO TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE WILL GO TO WYOMING, MONTANA,
PLACES THE UNITED STATES HAS
ENERGY.
WE PRODUCE ENERGY AND A MUCH
MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
WAY THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY.
THE SQUAD NEEDS TO HEAR ABOUT
THAT TOO APPEAR THEY ARE WORRIED
ABOUT THE LEFT AND ICC PUT OUT
ANOTHER REPORT TODAY THE
CLAIMANT, WE HAD TO WORRY ABOUT
THE CLAIMANT AND RIGHT NOW
WORRIED ABOUT ACTUAL SURVIVAL OF
THE WESTERN WORLD.
THAT IS WHAT WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT.
>> Jesse: EXACTLY.
WHAT WILL IT LOOK LIKE MEMORIAL
DAY WEEKEND WHEN PEOPLE START TO
HIT THE ROAD, TAKE THE KIDS ON A
TRIP AND IT IS $4.50 A GALLON,
$100 TO FILL UP YOUR TANK?
HOW DID THE DEMOCRATS SURVIVE
POLITICALLY?
>> Dan: IT WOULD BE HARD FOR
ANYBODY BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO
BE HAPPY IF IT IS $4.50
MEMORIAL DAY.
IF YOU ARE LOOKING WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW.
I AGREE WITH A LOT OF WHAT SHE
SAID, BUT I AGREE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
THAT BUILD NUCLEAR, FRACK AND
DRILL HAVE TO BE PART OF THE
LEXICON AND CLIMATE CHANGE BILL.
JUST LIKE CRAZIES ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE: STABLE THINKERS
ON REPUBLICAN SIDE AND
DEMOCRATIC THINKERS AS WELL AND
WE HAVE TO SHARE WITH THEM ALL.
TWO PRIOR TO COVID, PROVED COVID
OR BARRELS PER DAY USAGE IN
AMERICA $100 MILLION,
103 MILLION BARRELS A DAY.
NOW DOWN TO
202,196.2 BILLION BARRELS A DAY.
SO IF IT GETS BACK UP TO WHERE
IT WAS BEFORE PRICES COULD GO
BACK UP SO TINA, THE RECORD
PRICES WE WENT DOWN DURING COVID
WE WILL FIND OURSELVES GOING
BACK UP.
FINALLY, THIS ENERGY THING I
STRUGGLE LIKE YOU DO, BRIAN AND
THE WORST OF ACTION.
WE ASK THE SAUDIS TO PRODUCE
MORE?
THERE ARE THINGS WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THERE AND
CERTAINLY POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE
THINGS.
DO WE GO TO VENEZUELA, THE
IRANIANS?
I DON'T KNOW.
I WOULD RATHER GO TO VENEZUELA
BECAUSE I THINK WE CAN STRIKE A
SIMPLER DEAL, BUT I WILL LEAVE
THAT TO THE DIPLOMATS.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU $11 A BARREL,
WE WILL HAVE TO ASK VOTERS IN
PENNSYLVANIA, TEXAS,
SOUTH DAKOTA WHICH ONES THEY
LIKE.
>> Jesse: LET'S HEAR FROM
AMERICA'S GREATEST DIPLOMAT,
JUDGE JEANINE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Judge Jeanine: ACTUALLY I'M
THE ONLY ONE AT THE TABLE --
OKAY.
SORRY.
>> Jesse: WHICH YOU NEGOTIATE
WITH VENEZUELANS?
>> Judge Jeanine: NOT A
CHANCE.
I DON'T WANT THEIR OIL I DON'T
WANT BIDEN MIKE IRAN'S WILL OR
RUSSIAN SOIL.
I WANT AMERICAN OIL.
THE ONE THAT MADE SENSE TODAY
ELON MUSK.
WHEN ELON MUSK SAID DECREASED
DOMESTIC OIL OUTPUT WHILE
ACKNOWLEDGING IT WILL NEGATIVELY
IMPACT HIS ENERGY CAR BUSINESS.
HE SAID EXTRAORDINARY TIMES
DEMAND EXTRAORDINARY ACTIONS AND
IT WAS LIKE DRILL, BABY, DRILL
PEER THAT IS WHAT WE GOT TO DO
IS DRILL.
AND DON'T SAY SIMPLISTIC BECAUSE
WE DID IT.
WHEN WE DID IT, THE GAS WAS
CHEAP AND IT WAS CLEAN AND THEN